الى ملف اخر في المنتصف قال الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان انها على ستوكهولم عدم
انتظار دعم تركيا لقبول عضويتها في النيتو
اما السويد فاكدت سعيها كرئيسه للاتحاد
الاوروبي لتقويه التعاون مع النيتو المزيد
مع مراسلين من انقره مراسلنا المعتز بالله
حسن من بروكسل مراسلنا عبد الله الشامي
وابدا معك المعتز بالله حسن اذا واضح ان
يعني هناك نوع من المواجهه بين
الاتراك همم السويديين فيما يتعلق بقضيه
الانضمام هل من جديد من الجانب التركي
تفاصيل الموقف التركي تفضل
نعم ليلى كما انصب زيتا على نار الخلاف
بين السويد وتركيا جاءت عمليه او حادثه
احراق نسخه من القران الكريم في السويد
لتزيد التوتر الموجود اصلا بين تركيا
والسويد على خلفيه قيام مظاهرات مناوئه
لتركيا للرئيس اردوغان في العاصمه
السويديه كانت انقره تهمتها بانها تغض
النظر عن هذه همم الاحداث وانها ان السويد
لا تقوم بما يكفي همم فيما يتعلق بمكافحه
الارهاب بحسب وصفه انقره الرئيس التركي
كان يتحدث عن امس وقال انا علي السويد ان
لا تنتظر دعما من تركيا فيما يتعلق بعضويه
نيته همم وذلك تعليقا على هاتين الحديثتين
ايضا اليوم كان هناك تعليقات
وتمديدات همم من قبل جهه عده سياسيه هنا
في همم العاصمه انقره من بينها المتحدث
باسم رئاسه التركيه والذي قال انه لا يمكن
ان يتم التعبير عن هذه في الجريمه التي
وصفها بانها الجريمه الفاشيه
بالتعبير عنها بانها حريه تعبير ايضا
المعارضه التركيه انتقدت هذه الحادثه وراى
زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض بان هذه
الحادثه من شانها ان تزيد الاوضاع سوءا
بين كل من السويد وتركيا اذا هناك تمديدات
عده بما جرى في السويد وانقره تقول انها
مصممه على موقفها فيما يتعلق بعضويه
السويد في النيجر